this performance with the pops
is probably one of the most exciting
ones i've done
it's my first time playing with a
professional orchestra
the focus of my phd is machine learning
and statistics
and i'm investigating theoretical
questions like how much data do you need
in order to actually make a good
decision
[Music]
it's great having music as an outlet to
just be able to do something in your
free time
and to just kind of switch your mind out
of research and focus on something
different and activate different areas
of your brain
i think my younger self will be elated
to hear that i was playing with the pops
because
i would always like watch a youtube
recording of like their
stars and stripes forever performance
and i was always inspired by that i just
watched every fourth of july so
when you come into the practice rooms at
mit you're supposed to
disinfect the keys before and after you
practice
and then it just makes a sound like it
sounds like this
so you just hear that in the practice
rooms a lot when people are coming in
and leaving to practice
[Music]
i gave a recital recently that
had just a few members of the live
audience i had to wear a mask when i was
performing
the rest of the people watched on zoom
so it was nice because i could have
my friends in california watch
so i chose to play the romanov concerto
because first of all it's a great piece
of music
and it's just also very close to my
heart because i've been
playing it for quite a while i learned
it four years ago
i do like the first movement for it's
beautiful lyrical things but
there's some also deeper angst i guess
the solo sections of this piece are very
intimate and
there's a lot of beauty in them they're
very
passionate and loving but it's also
kind of sad and bittersweet
i guess in a time pandemic sometimes you
don't want to plunge into something
completely new
maybe different people have different
ways of coping but i like to go back to
what i
originally liked and rediscover what i
liked about it
i think one of the most important things
about music is that you can kind of take
away what you want to take away from it
there's a lot of interpretive history
the different people play different ways
i hope that my particular way of playing
resonates in you and somehow
brings you joy
you